Ryan al-Najar, an 18-year-old woman from
Syria, was found lifeless in the
Netherlands. Her father had ordered her
brothers, Muhammad and Muhammad, aged 23
and 25, to control her. Because in an
Islamic state, the father and the two
sons will get capital punishment
straight away. Our innocent sister Ryan,
may Allah have mercy on her, is going to
ask you, you evil dirt bags, the father
and the brothers, for what sin of mine
did you kill me? For what did I do?
Ladies and gentlemen from all around the
world, today is Sunday, July the 27th,
2025 and we gathered here in South of
Gaza Strip most to share our concerns
about the ongoing crisis in Gaza Strip.
During the humanitarian crisis that Gaza
and his people are undergoing,
food in general and flour, bread
especially, it's becoming luxurious and
rare, it's not available for the
citizens. So our mission here to support
the citizens and to help their their
lives to be better by giving them these
trips. On behalf of those citizens and
those families, we thank what forever
for his wonderful support. It will be a
reason and making the people happy.
Thank you for being a reason in this
effort.
Everalam
welcome to brothers and sisters and dear
friends in so this video I came across
subhan allah And it really really
agitated me. Really angered me for two
reasons. Number one, an innocent woman.
She's innocent who was killed, gagged,
drowned, and God knows what else. Her
own brothers done at the command of
their evil father.
This is a real life misogyny. The word
we use very loosely to people that don't
deserve it. This is what he call
misogyny. This is what he call
misguidance. This is what he call devas.
This what you call it jah ignorance to
take a woman's life because she had a
boyfriend or she had whatever. Look look
these these things in Islam are not
permissible. Nowhere in Islam does it
say you can take a human being's life
that because they had a boyfriend or
were living a western way of life. So
much so even if that girl was having sex
outside of marriage which she was not
which is a slander. And I can remember
this like yesterday where I had to
travel to France about 12 years ago
because of another sister called Aisha
who threw herself out the window because
her brothers were about to beat up
because of a video circulating about her
committing zena. This is what we mean.
This attitude is ignorance. Nowhere in
Islam does it say this. Let's watch some
videos, inshallah, and see what the
people had to say and come back in.
Here's here's a video.
>> This woman was killed simply because she
chose to live a western lifestyle. Ryan
al- Najar, an 18-year-old woman from
Syria, was found lifeless in the
Netherlands. Her father had ordered her
brothers, Muhammad and Muhammad, aged 23
and 25, to control her because she had a
boyfriend and embraced a western way of
life. He didn't approve of her choices,
so he sent her brothers to silence her,
to restrain her, and ultimately to throw
her into a swamp near Amsterdam. Her
father, Khaled Al- Naja, remains in
Syria and gave the orders from there.
When she was found, there were signs of
a struggle, including marks under her
fingernails that suggested she fought
back, possibly against one of her
brothers. Now her brothers are in the
Netherlands while her father stays in
Syria. He claims responsibility for
disowning her and is trying to protect
his children from going to prison. This
tragic situation unfolded because
according to their cultural beliefs, she
dishonored the family simply by living a
western lifestyle.
So in an Islamic state, the father and
the two sons will get capital punishment
straight away. Okay? They will get
capital punishment because they
committed a murder. This is vigilantism.
Who are you to go there and take a
person? It's so deep. Allah subhana wa
tala says in the Quran, brothers and
sisters, yeah, before we go to the next
reaction video of another person, subhan
Allah, Allah subhanaa tala in this
Quran. Yes. Okay.
Allah says, "And when the girl child
buried alive will be questioned." Yes.
For what crime or sin was she killed
for? What crime? The pagan Arabs before
Islam came to Arabian Peninsula were
known for this. They will kill their
daughters because of dishonor cuz they
thought if we go to war and we lose the
war, they're going to take our girls and
do whatever to them. Therefore, it's
better they are dead or for whatever
reasons they degraded woman. Islam came
to honor woman. And this verse shows
clearly what that the Quran is saying
when that girl who's buried alive, she's
going to ask on the day of judgment for
what sin did you kill me? And this girl,
our innocent sister Ryan, may Allah have
mercy on her, is going to ask you, you
evil dirt bags, the father and the
brothers, for what sin of mine did you
kill me? For what did I do? What sin?
Even if she committed a sin, it is
forbidden in Islam for you to take the
life of anyone on your uh own hands
which she has not done anything.
Islamically, a man, a sahaba found his
wife in bed with another man. He came to
the prophet peace be upon him and he
said, "I saw my wife in a in bed with
another man." The prophet said, "Do you
know what you just said? You are going
to be um whipped for lying because in
Islam, do you have evidence?" No
evidence. You're getting whipped for
slander cuz Islam deals highly with the
honor of a woman in a good way to defend
the honor because they know how it is
that the woman gets slandered easily.
Subhan Allah. Yes. So it's they were
going to get whipped and revelation came
down and protected him by telling his
wife to take four oaths by Allah and the
fifth of the curse of God be on them and
the man had to do the same thing that
they both escape the punishment. This is
what Islam is. People are going and
thinking this is the this is the um you
know something to do with Islam. This
has zero to do with Islam. If anything
Islam came to combat this and I'm going
to go to another video actually which
you can see in let's just quickly go to
that one.
>> An 18year-old girl goes missing. Days
later, she's found in a swamp, tied,
gagged, left to drown. And prosecutors
say her brothers did it. Not strangers,
not criminals off the street, her
brothers. And they're claiming they did
it because her western behavior brought
shame on the family. And it gets worse.
The father, the one prosecutors say
ordered it, is nowhere to be found. He
fled to Syria the moment the
investigation tightened. Dutch
authorities can't reach him. He's gone.
Now, here's the uncomfortable truth.
When stories like this break, people
across Europe don't just see a murder.
They see a mindset, an old brutal family
code operating inside modern European
borders. So, we saw it, brothers and
sisters, panel, as you can see. And this
man has a point. Okay? If you are from a
country, you don't follow Islam and you
want to come to the west and you you
have some honor code around yourself,
whatever. Why you coming to the west,
bro? Why are you coming to the west?
Don't come to the west because the
western world has a specific value. Yes,
the girls can do whatever they like.
They can have sex before marriage. They
can drink the man what? No problem. If
you don't like their values, why are you
coming to the west? Yes. Why? Because
you care more about the money. Okay. If
you care about your honor and your honor
values so much which is unislamic, stay
where you are. With all you say, this is
coming from a Muslim. My family's
immigrants. Okay. With all due respect,
if you live in a area in a country where
you have a conduct of code or honor
killing or whatever this is, if you care
about that so much, you should stick to
that honor value and stay where you are.
Because if you know you're going to come
to the west and the west is going to
entice or call your daughters or sons to
do certain things that you don't like
and you're going to take the matters in
their own hand and kill them whatever
that matter don't come to the west my
friend why are you coming to the west
yes cuz you're more care about what you
honor is what the money and when you
come here and this happens you take the
matters in your own hands this is
disgusting this is vile this has zero to
do with Islam there is not a single
verse in the Quran or the sunnah that
says you can kill an innocent girl may
Allahh have mercy on sister Rayan and
sister Aisha 12 years ago who I had to
go to France to the ghettos to find out
what happened to her to defend her
honor. Yes. Because she was killed. Why?
Because her brothers wanted to attack
her, beat her. She jumped out the
window. Subhan Allah. The video is this.
If you still guys want to watch in when
I went to France 12 years ago, this
breaks my heart. It hurts me that Islam
is brought into this. It hurts me more
that an innocent girl going about her
business. Maybe because of rumors. And
let me tell you something, even if she
did, which is an absolute slander lie,
did something immoral, nowhere in Islam
does it say you can do this. So this is
why we need capital punishment. These
three men and his father should be
hanged. Yes. Should be executed
Islamically. Yes. In an Islamic land.
But what can you do? Get a little hot
water, hot baths, hot bed. Brilliant.
May Allah subhana wa tala give grant ja
to the sister. May Allah forgive her
sins and give her inshallah. Subhan
Allah. And let her testify to Allah on
the brother and sisters when you're
doing for the inah please remember
sister Rayan and sister Aisha and many
people who have died to honor killings
in your duas inshallah. And when you're
doing just remember them inshallah it
will be for them. Till next timealamu.
May Allahh protect us and allow us to
follow the true form of Islam. Goodbye.